I got Hands-On with the new iPhone 15
Pros here's two colors left is the
natural titanium and on the right is the
titanium white the titanium finishes on
these new iPhones are actually really
beautiful and the phones themselves are
super light the entire new iPhone lineup
is equipped with USBC as you can see
here along with another huge change of
there's no more silent switch it's been
replaced with this action button that
you can customize with various different
actions inside of the settings you can
change it to focus mode to open up the
camera a flashlight voice memo magnifier
a shortcut or accessibility settings
I'll be setting mine to open up the
camera you'll be able to choose if you
wanted to open the front-facing camera
record a video so when you press and
hold the action button now my camera
pops up and I can instantly start taking
photos or videos like I'm constantly
always trying to take photos of videos
so being able to quickly open the camera
we love to see it